- Remember that package you received
when you got into Yale?
Well it's high time you receive another.
Since we cannot distribute
the typical items
of the Class Day celebration,
we've instead shipped
every member of our class a
special Class Day CARE Package.
The box includes many of
the traditional items:
the anthology that Sarah
told us about yesterday,
a Yale College pin, a handkerchief
like the one we received
during our first week at Yale,
though this time sponsored
by the Yale Alumni Association
for Bright College Years this Sunday.
Some of the traditional
items we are keeping
for our future in-person ceremony
such as the clay pipes that we
traditionally smash together
on Old Campus, but don't worry.
We're gonna get to do that too.
The CARE Package also includes
some special elements for this year.
We've added the tassels that would've come
with your Commencement gown as well as
a special Yale photo banner.
Whether you're wearing a suit and tie
or you're still wearing those pajamas
you put on in March,
be sure to post a photo
with the banner and share it, #Yale2020.
And now to the main attraction of the day,
the comedic reflection
by Simon Fraser, J.E.,
and Oscar Lopez Aguirre, Hopper.
We all could use some laughs right now
and Simon and Oscar sure can deliver.
So here's to them.
- Hey Oscar.
Oh I think you're muted.
- [Oscar] Am I, oh, sorry, thank you.
Is it, am I good?
Am I good?
- You're great, you're great.
Should we give this speech then?
- The one we wrote the
day before Spring Break?
- That's the one.
- I don't know, do you
think it'll be an issue
that some stuff has happened since?
- I don't see it affecting
our speech that much.
- Okay, let's do it.
- Pray, President Salovey.
- Dean Chun.
- Michelle Obama.
- Family.
- Friends.
- Uninvited cousins.
- It is so great to be
in New Haven speaking
to the thousands of you so close together.
The Elm City, the 06511,
east of West Haven,
west of East Haven, unfair of Fair Haven,
isn't it just a beautiful, beautiful day
in sunny, sunny New Haven?
There's a reason we endure
eight months of rain
and snow and gloom and improv shows
for days like these in New Haven.
- Yeah Simon, sorry, I'm
actually seeing a problem
with the speech.
- What is it?
- Well our speech is ten minutes
and currently you spend
six of those talking
about how nice it is to be in New Haven.
- What's your point?
- Well we're not actually in New Haven.
- I am.
- I thought Yale kicked us all out.
- They did but old Dean of
Pearson still has a house here
and she's letting me stay in
exchange for a few favors.
- What favors?
- Just some Yelp reviews.
I'm just kidding, I live off campus.
- Of course you do.
- What?
- Nothing.
You know what, should we just do
our more up-to-date speech then?
- That sounds good.
We are here to celebrate
the Class of 2020.
What an iconic class.
Not since the class of 1010
and not until the class
of 42069 will that be a
more iconic class year.
I remember when I got
accepted, early action, legacy.
- Regular Decision, poor.
- And I was like I'm
going to take a gap year,
and then I was like, class of 2021?
(mimics vomiting)
- Okay Simon, really, you puked?
You had a bodily response to a class year?
So immature.
They are just as special
as those who came before us
like the Class of 20 (mimics vomiting).
Wait, what's happening, wait, I'm scared.
You try it?
- Class of 20 (mimics vomiting).
- 20 (mimics vomiting).
Okay, I think we gotta move on then.
What an almost four years we had.
- This year the big
celebration was Yale 50.
- That's right, Simon.
Papa Johns continues to
give half off all pizzas
with the code "Yale50".
What a deal!
- No, no Oscar, Yale celebrated 50 years
of women being at the college,
which is crazy when you think about it
because us guys are only here for four.
- Coming to Yale was daunting.
Before we arrived on campus,
we didn't know so many things.
We didn't know if we were going
to be friends with our roommates,
we didn't know what
classes we were gonna take,
we didn't know if we were going to fit in,
but we did know that even
if everything else failed,
we would all have at least one friend.
- George Iskander!
- Hey George, how's it going?
- It's going well guys, just eating some--
- That's enough, George.
In our four years, we have seen so much
and we have achieved so much.
In our class we have Rhodes
Scholars and Woads Scholars.
- We have finance bros and astrology hoes,
I'm in the latter, varsity
athletes who put their heart
and soul into their sport.
We also have the rugby team.
- We have actors and writers,
new journalists and the YDN.
- We have CCE instructors
who taught us about consent
by having us ask another person
if they wanted to get Froyo.
- Since then, only my FOOT
group has asked me to get Froyo?
- You didn't do FOOT?
- That's the joke.
- And we have friends in acapella groups
who taught about consent when they say,
"You really don't have to
come if you don't want to,"
and we didn't.
- We've had grade inflation.
- Though not as much as that
smuck ol' school in Cambridge.
(forced laughing)
- We had Feb club.
What a money-making sham that was.
I paid $29 to only go to the first party,
which was at my house.
- Speaking of paying for parties,
are we getting that $125
in your dues refund?
Last time I checked,
making TikTok was free.
- In our years at Yale, we've
had world renowned scholars
teach us critical thinking
in all different fields.
- And now most of us will
be applying to those fields
to make the world of
finance a better place.
I however am actually
using my critical thinking
to question why the Lily
Pad is on top of Toad's.
If the toad's drowning,
who's gonna save it.
Yes I'm unemployed, but aren't we all?
- Oscar, it's not the Lily
Pad, it's actually Lily's Pad?
- Well, who's Lily?
Is her name short of Lillian or Liliana?
Is that the toad's name?
It must be, I took first order logic.
- While we were here, we won the Game
three out of four times.
- And the one time we lost
was on a baseball field.
Now I may have just learned
that a "down" isn't when
a football player is feeling sad,
but I'm pretty sure that
means it doesn't count.
Every touchdown was a home run.
During this most recent game,
a group of Yale students united
to protest climate change.
- And Puerto Rican debt, Oscar.
- Okay, but I'm Latino
so I can't say that.
This protest caused some criticism
and the criticism went like this.
Why would these students decide to protest
the most hollowed of sporting events
that would maximize
viewership and exposure
not only on campus but the alumni
and those watching the
game across the nation,
and the answer still eludes me.
It just makes no sense,
why would they do that?
- Of course, we also
had the Privilege War.
For those who don't remember,
at the start of freshman year,
all the FroCo's had to
step forward if we ever had
some sort of privilege, and
I don't know about you Oscar,
but for me, what a workout!
God, they had me moving a lot.
Have you traveled to
more than five countries?
Yes I have!
Have you ever played tennis?
Let me step forwards!
Do you pronounce it "finance"?
I just did.
Wow, I've never moved more.
- Yeah I know, right?
Totally agree.
- Wait, you moved too?
- Yeah, but they have me move backwards.
- There was Psych and the Good Life,
Yale's biggest ever
class, and the best part
about that class was that
no one did what they said
they would do in their
final paper proposal.
I said I was going to
meditate for four hours a day
for two weeks, and then I sat
down for like five minutes
and got bored and opened Instagram.
- What was that, Simon?
- Sorry, you're muted I think?
- I'm definitely not muted.
- No, you are.
- But then how did you know what I said?
- Sorry!
- Wait.
- You know, I didn't take
Psych and the Good Life.
- Oh, why's that?
- Intro ER&M was at the
same, so no judgment
but I guess we have different
definitions of self-care.
- We had the admissions
scandal which showed
how getting into college
isn't always a meritocracy.
- But Vice didn't interview me about it
so in a way I guess I'm
richer than I thought,
kind of upper-middle working class?
Also I want to take this
time to say thank you
on behalf of myself and
all the other people
who also never sent a
letter to their donor,
so to my donor, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Of course, coronavirus came
which has brought so much
unimaginable drama to an
already dramatic four years.
Coronavirus taught us a lot.
- For me it was learning just
how many people go on cruises.
- And for me it was just how seriously
the Spring Fling committee takes its job.
When the world had already
practically stopped,
the campus was shut down for good
and the CDC had banned gatherings
of more than 10 people,
the Spring Fling committee
sent out an email saying
they had tried every option but had made
the incredibly tough and
not obvious at all decision
to cancel Spring Fling,
and I applaud that spirit.
- Coronavirus meant we also
lost out on a lot of things,
including Senior Week.
- Tonight would've been Erotica,
which for those who
don't know is one night
when the entire senior
class goes to Toad's
wearing only underwear.
- Oscar?
- Yeah, sorry, I think I got muted.
I was trying to say that Erotica is when--
- What is happening?
- Yeah, I don't think Yale
will let me describe Erotica.
- Why not?
All that is is when 1,000
seniors put on lingerie--
- They, yeah they don't, and there's--
(audio cuts out)
So big senior pizza party.
- There we go.
Oscar, how are you
dealing with the effects
of coronavirus in L.A.?
- Well, I was trying
to make the most of it
so I went to Universal Studios today
but they wouldn't let me in.
- That makes sense, they
were probably closed
because of the virus.
- Yeah, but I was like, I
don't think you understand.
I have a Universal pass.
I lobbied the Yale
administration for this.
I emailed like the U.S.
but they still escorted me
from the premises and
threatened to arrest me.
- No Oscar, "Universal Pass"
was the policy adopted by Yale
where all grades became pass/fail.
But that didn't mean our
academic standards slipped.
- Simon, I read an essay
you wrote, it was terrible.
- Well, that's not true.
- Your opening line was, "Emily Dickinson
"and Pablo Neruda were
two different people."
- Some people have doubts about that.
- It was your final paper for Spanish.
- Your point?
- You wrote it in English.
- Coronavirus also meant
that since people faced
different working
conditions away from campus,
some departments didn't award
prizes for senior theses,
but what the university
hasn't announced yet
is that because we were all
apart for these last few months,
those big prizes, the ones
for the best people at Yale,
they're gone too.
Sorry, Sedurin.
- I guess we'll never know if
I was going to win the award
for Best Community Member
in Branford College.
- Oscar, you're in Hopper.
- I guess we'll never know.
- No, we're kidding, there
will be the big prizes
but they don't always
cover every category.
Therefore we have decided
to do our own prize giving.
- First up for Most Piggybacks in Section
is everyone who took the S.
- Then it's not sunny too often,
but for the best tan congratulations
to Saybrook's own Tan Tan Wang.
- And finally a familiar
face for the Best Memer,
George Iskander.
- It's a real honor to win this--
- Bye George.
We left Yale too early
and we had different Yale experiences.
Some of us never had the
Tuna Tartar at Harvest.
- And some of us still
think Shades of Yale
is a Facebook group for
overheard insults on campus.
- And it is all too easy to be engulfed
in the current moment,
but for as many bad things
as we've gone through, there have been
so many more good things.
- We've shared late lunches at Commons
and we've shared late nights at butteries.
- We've shared photos on Facebook
and we've shared study
guides on Google Docs.
- We've shared seats
at sold out dance shows
and we've shared utter contempt
for the other college in IMs.
- We've shared Franzia at parties
and some of us shared Froyo in the sacks
and although Yale was different for us all
and we all leave here having
our own personal connection
to it, we all leave sharing one thing:
the ugliest diploma in America.
When you get it, just look at it
and remind yourself of this speech.
- So once this pandemic
ends and the next time
you're in New York or L.A. or New York
and you see another person
in the Class of 2020,
maybe you'll wave to them like you did
your entire time at
Yale after you met once
in the Zeta basement.
- But even if you don't, you'll still know
that both of you share being
part of the most iconic class
and community at Yale since 1010
and still have so much more to share.
- Here's to the class of 2020.
- Oh my God!
- We got it!
That was crazy.
I can't believe this
should be in the video too.
I think we had it--
- That was so bad.
- Thank God, Jesus Christ.
- Oh my God.
- Two days of work.
Whoa, that was psycho.
- We got it, we got it.
- No wonder 1917 won 'cause Jesus Christ,
to do anything in one shot, wow.
Jeez.
- Oh my God, wow.
That was--
- That was crazy.
- This is joy.
This is--
- This is, I've never felt
a rush of euphoria like this in a while.
And now to start writing
the one we're gonna have
to deliver live next year.